[Music]
well good morning everybody it's another
beautiful day I'm gonna go out and catch
some catfish just got kind of a relaxing
day today and it's a good thing too
because tomorrow is gonna be crazy
accidentally double-booked two charters
in one day I'm going fishing for my
early morning until early afternoon and
then I'm going high Chthon hunting from
early afternoon until like the next
morning so I'm gonna be up for about 24
hours
fishing and hunting and I'm gonna be
exhausted so today is going to be
low-key
look at this they make runs
with the nice little bend in the rock
all right there's one my rod is my
Japanese rod that's a $200 rod real
kombu they can see it it's floating I
wanted to jump in but there's no ladder
on this dock if I jump in I cannot get
back in up here
there is no ladder oh there isn't a
single dock on this whole side of the
canal that has a ladder on it oh I
didn't loosen the drag that is the first
rod I have ever lost that way that is
the first rod I've ever lost from a fish
stealing it well the fishings picked up
but I find that I've been emotionally
devastated by losing my rod and it's
helped me refocus on what's important in
my life so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's really good to see the
boys learning how to swim without the
life vests you know I try to be so
careful with them always in their life
that's when we go fishing but you know
eventually they're gonna fall in it's
gonna happen one day they're gonna
really fall in and it's nice to know
that they can swim a little redundancy
isn't a bad thing well I'm glad I took a
little break and took the opportunity to
mourn the loss of my fishing rod and
play with my children but I'm gonna see
if we can't pick up a few more here
and see what's see what we can find okay
look what just happened
I just broke about 6 inches off the tip
of my hundred twenty-five dollar Nash
dope what happened is I was trying to
pull some line out to work with as I
tied it and this line got caught okay
the drags off so it should have just
pulled out but because the line was
wrapped around there when I pulled it it
got stuck and it snapped the tip off so
I have now lost one imported Japanese
rod and reel combo and I've now broken
my British telescopic fishing rod oh
yeah hey baby boy yeah okay when you get
back I'm gonna need another hug don't
let go over the rod it's the only one I
got left yeah I'm glad you guys are
hanging out with me why fish it's fun
he'll hold you Apple don't work yeah
well at the end of another wonderful day
and what better way to end it then with
barbeque yes
so we're gonna eat up and then I'm
getting to bed early because tomorrow I
am got a long day that includes fishing
for sheep head and wrestling pythons at
night in the swamp so all right see you
guys in the morning good morning
everybody
6:30 in the morning and me and Tommy are
the only ones out I was getting up
making myself some breakfast getting
ready to sneak out to go do a sheep head
fishing charter all right me and Tommy
we're getting ready to meet John we're
gonna go out again but this time we're
gonna be aiming for some sheeps head I'm
gonna try to do a little catch and cook
video here excited buddy all right take
a seat bud it's a beautiful day John you
excited to go catch a seat Jenn we're
real lucky we might catch the whole
sheep
he's come here semana DS they just went
underwater but there's some manatees
right there I'm gonna keep the line
still but tight okay and if you feel
like a little tap tap tap tap on your
rod you let me know really real real
real real real real really oh there you
go bud yeah you want step backwards
walking that's a pretty fish right the
corner of the mouth job buddy look at
the bottom ones they're perfectly
straight and that's that's how they
that's how they eat the oysters and then
spit the clams how they got crushers in
I laughs so this is a mangrove snapper
or a gray snapper and they this is a
pretty decent sized one the minimum
limits 10 inches and he's a big old boy
but check out the teeth on these guys he
has pointy fangs tell me this duck the
double
not long yeah right over there see right
there it's adolphus see that see him
right there oh look this one right here
he just went right under the boat
probably those same two we saw you know
there's those dolphins are fastened with
ribbon right past its Mazzoli like three
feet of water so you can see it really
well look at this little piece of meat
that's really it I go wrestle a snake
that oh yeah all right tell me you ready
to go see mama hi baby
[Music]
now I'm heading off to the Everglades
I'm gonna be me a guy by the name of
Mike I hope to go hunt Burmese pythons
all night long and to say I'm excited is
a gross understatement
we better get going though I have two
and a half hours of Drive well guys I
haven't eaten lunch and I'm gonna need
dinner second dinner midnight snack
probably an early breakfast than actual
breakfast so I ordered eight double
cheeseburgers well apparently pythons
will only eat things they can swallow a
hole so the bigger you are the safer you
are so safety first
no Python hitting me driving through the
Everglades right now and it is just
awesome oh there's so many places I want
to stop and fish and explore I can spend
months here this is amazing alright guy
I met up with Mike we're gonna go get
ourselves some pythons I am beyond
stoked we're gonna make it happen for
sure we're going to the secret no
trespassing going to go to jail
location trespassing is a felony geez
robbery kids never go to a second
location with somebody you met online
unless they're a Python hunter that's
okay now what these are these are
Burmese pythons these are people's pets
that some yo hos let loose into the
swamp thinking they were given their
pets a better life and now these things
have established a breeding population
here in Southwest Florida just causing
havoc but the government has
commissioned certain bounty hunters so
to speak about 25 ive hunters that are
allowed to go on government property and
hunt for these things and they get paid
a bounty
so these professional snake hunters like
Mike are going around trying their best
to try to put a check on these Burmese
snake these Burmese pythons now when we
see one is it the kind of thing where we
just bail out of this car and run as
fast as we can
you know we don't want to scare the
snake we want to kind of make it seem
like we don't even see it it's real
camouflage they like to wait and see
what you're gonna do so it's gonna freak
out gonna freak out
we're just scanning scanning and
scanning for a big fat six foot plus
snake this is pretty awesome being out
here at now you're getting to see a part
of the Everglades that people normally
don't get to see and it's just I'm on
pins and needles you know it's the
wintertime we may not see any pythons or
we might see a bunch we just don't know
if I saw one in the water over there
with that just be like sorry out of luck
don't even try it you know
alright go ahead and grab its tail now
and yeah grab its hail and hold on do
not let go nice job now it this snakes
kind of cooled down this is good it's
gonna make it a little bit easier slowly
work your way up towards towards its
head kind of wait for it wait for a
chance to to get it when it's kind of
stopped and calm down
beautiful like a pro nicely done
very nice yeah you gotta follow Mike on
Instagram he's got he's got an amazing
Instagram page on there so I'm gonna put
a link in the description as far as the
catch and cook part of this video Oh
what happens with these snakes is he's
got to take him to a biologist between
Monday through Friday at certain times
and it's Saturday morning right now and
I'm gonna be leaving Florida before
Monday so what he's gonna do is he's
gonna go ahead take it to the biologist
they're gonna return the meat back to
him he's gonna ship it to me in Virginia
and then we're gonna do the second half
of this video where we cook up the
Python I've got a two and a half hour
drive back to Cape Coral and I think I
need to load up on some soda and maybe
pick up a souvenir for the boys too
alright got Tommy and Nathan some
alligator paw keychains
they'll think that's pretty cool so
what's my secret the same so
lerton focused while driving bollywood
music
I made it and I'm tired come here I got
I got some souvenirs for you it's an
alligator hand keychain this Jacobs
birthday he turned one-years-old today
we got the whole crew in here and we are
gonna do some lunch
over there
with me yeah they're sheepshead down
there today is our second to last full
day in Florida and it's Jacob's birthday
and this poor little guy is not feeling
well he is sick a little fever a little
cold and I'm just gonna cuddle it now
we're really gonna do much of any
fishing with him I think that's what he
needs today plus I am exhausted but the
boys are having a ball in the swimming
pool with Grandpa and tonight we're
gonna eat some delicious fresh seafood I
think that's gonna be just enough for
today
looking pretty good
[Music]
there we go guys the ultimate Florida
dinner plates
Sheepshead scallops stone crab fresh hot
shrimp a little bit of mango it's not
too bad well it is the end of a very
long Saturday and I am absolutely
exhausted hopefully we'll be feeling a
little bit better tomorrow and I'm just
gonna do a few things here on the
computer and download some SD cards and
I'm going to bed see you guys in the
morning
well hey everyone and welcome to our
last full day here in Florida Jakob's
doing a little bit better his fever
seems to have broken and he stopped
blowing chunks on everyone and
everything he threw up a lot last night
but he's doing well and today we're just
kind of packing up and getting
everything ready to go cuz we're
checking out early tomorrow to head back
to Virginia well church went pretty well
we got ourselves fairly packed so now
we're gonna hop in the car do a little
Sunday Drive and hide some of those
treasure boxes we promised but leave for
you guys alright
[Music]
alright guys this is one of my best
treasure boxes here and I think we're
gonna find a really great spot to hide
this as far as you can there you go
well guys it's been a great trip and
we've had a load of fun but it's time to
go home and we're driving back to
Virginia about 15 hours give or take
depending on traffic and we're gonna
hide a couple more of those treasure
boxes on our way back and don't forget
we're put in the description the GPS
coordinates and little hint so you guys
can find them self that out but I better
get the car packed yeah that was no fun
did you guys have a good time yeah
alright now we've got 14 hours and 40
minutes back to Virginia
so without stops so let's get to it I'm
out here looking for a place to hide a
treasure box unfortunately this place
has an alligator
all right three boxes down two to go
just watch out for alligators well guys
we made it home we hope you enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
travel adventures from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe and check out the playlist in
our description for more great videos
like this have a great day thanks for
watching we hope you enjoyed this video
if you want to see part one of the
Florida adventure click the link below
also if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning and don't forget to check out
the catfish and carp youtube channel
where we post all of our fishing videos
thanks for watching